ah
here
when it finished
now you
have to eat
well what was
it for I don't have left
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
that's right
and
now today
the connection is over
[Music]
after the transition it happened to me in function
working  you are seeing in the minister more
peter a
the way
chris froome it is true
although navarra has been
repeat it
sperisen
efe episode
night until camp
croft they are going to use
snow more navy seals and the das
com
legislation
mr silver
the about
andrés santacruz
yes
it
is not very
hot  what are
replicas
not only does cancer camp
your voice
and
the one from yesterday is better
blue honestly they
change more
fresh hair
well this face to tve
v
[Music]
yes
those lines would die but in that
my father informed me
[Music]
leftover
kitchen paper stuff
now
[Music]
blazers